[Musik]
die frage ist nur ob jetzt noch genug
luft rein kommt oder ob ich gleich im
schlaf das wäre auch zu kommen youtuber
in babbel zählt im schlaf gestorben dass
der jack russel wenn ich hier den pizza
bestellen kann ich weiß nicht ob das
geht glaubt an eltern gehen jetzt
schlafen die machen forderung das licht
aus nein das weiß der strom
naja fristlos einläutet ab und herzlich
willkommen zu einem neuen video ja doch
ich hoffe natürlich geht es gut mir auch
noch ich habe mir gerade schon mal so
ein bisschen alibi mäßig hier meine
mütze aufgesetzt und zwar habe ich das
ja auch schon jetzt angekündigt dieses
auto ego das steht immer noch also ich
habe es heute eingerichtet und das video
dazu schon fertig gedreht auch schon
fertig geschnitten und morgen wollte ich
eigentlich wieder nach köln fahren das
heißt mir bleibt nichts anderes übrig
als heute auch zumindest ist zu
versuchen vielleicht mal ein bisschen
länger darin verbringen also geplant ist
halt die ganze nacht aber wie es wird
ist natürlich auch ein bisschen dumm so
das ganze aber es könnte auch ein
abenteuer sein ich bin einfach mal
gespannt und ich glaube für so ein
youtube-video lohnt sich das mache ich
mein ich habe da jetzt ein fernseher
drin
an die leute die die ersten beiden
videos nicht geschaut haben schaut ihr
euch auf jeden fall erstmal an fernseher
playstation sofa oder so eine couch also
werden weshalb 10 ungefähr
ich habe mir jetzt hier vorne noch so
eine fleecejacke besorgt die mütze habe
ich ja schon auf dann nehme ich noch
eine decke mit und hab halt meine
jogginghose an das sollte erstmal
reichen weil in dem iglu ist es auf
jeden fall auch 56789 grad wärmer als
draußen zumindest wenn man ein bisschen
länger drin war gut dann würde ich sagen
will aber gar nicht lange gehen mal rein
und wenn mir spannend was passiert nach
scheiße leute jetzt bin ich schon drin
jetzt kann ich euch gar nicht mehr
zeigen wie es von außen aussieht auf
jeden fall heftig schaut euch dazu am
besten einmal das video von vorgestern
an der decke
[Musik]
hier ist dieser pulli am 1
meine jacke legte zum glück auch noch
pulli und decke
warum klingeln denn jetzt die glocken
guck mal das beschlägt sogar von innen
gibt euch das mal weiß jetzt hier drin
eigentlich sogar relativ angenehm warm
ist
[Musik]
ok dann gehen wir mal in mein
hotelzimmer ich habe auch gedacht
eigentlich kann ich das ja als airbnb
anbieten ich meine wo hat man das schon
mal so und dann mache ich mal hier die
tür zu
[Musik]
ich habe mir hier auf jeden fall mal ein
bisschen licht gelassen damit ich
einfach wenn ich was sehen möchte was
sehen kann oder damit es halt ein
bisschen halle ist keine ahnung
vielleicht mache ich das später noch aus
und ja kurzen ruhm tue hier ist der
fernseher flatscreen smart hdtv mit
youtube intonation allem was du brauchst
hier unten drunter ist noch die decke
playstation das ist hier die xxl couch
decke jetzt habe ich nicht mehr
hingelegt
hier haben wir auf jeden fall noch eine
zusätzliche lampe kann man ganz einfach
die stufen verstellen und dann aus oder
anmachen denen ja eigentlich eben noch
da oben wo jetzt die lichterkette hängt
würde ist dann halt runtergefallen alter
gebt euch mal wie das beschlägt man kann
ja gar nicht in den sternenhimmel sehen
was das denn ich dachte diese dinger
sind dafür um die pumpe geht mir schon
laufen sagt waffen macht hier kommt ja
die ganze luft raus und es ist auch
recht laut deswegen lege ich jetzt mal
küssen davor
ja das ist auf jeden fall angenehmer die
frage ist nur jetzt hört man viel mehr
die frage ist nun ob jetzt noch genug
luft rein kommt oder ob ich gleich im
schlaf das wäre auch zukommt youtuber in
babbel zählt im schlaf gestorben okay
das habe ich hier ist dieses vlies was
ich anziehen werde
damit wir waren genug bleibt
ok
okay das sieht auf jeden fall schon mal
besser aus
dann jetzt noch die decke also
eigentlich ganz bequem
ich weiß nur nicht ob das auf dauer warm
bleibt oder danach kalt wird aber ich
muss es ja jetzt erstmal so lassen die
pumpe ist jetzt zwar deutlich leiser
aber es geht mir immer noch offen sagt
okay was machen wir jetzt
ich habe mich eigentlich jetzt auch so
ein sternenmeer gefreut gibt keine
sterne heute kommt das erste video das
mir vorgeschlagen wird
dieser mann ist seit 25 jahren nur pizza
naja kommt schaue ich mir mal an scheiße
die fernbedienung ist irgendwie leer das
nur alter gibt euch mal auf der kamera
wie meistens auch aussieht also es ist
schon geil aber ich glaube das video
habe ich schon mal gesehen leute mist
ich habe gedacht eigentlich dass der
jack russel wenn ich hier den pizza
bestellen kann ich weiß nicht ob das
geht
wir können versuchen weil ich kenne ich
natürlich auch einige pizzerien so hier
kann man auf jeden fall bis 23 uhr
bestellen weil ich wohne ja so auf dem
dorf das habe ich mir nämlich auch
vorgenommen auf jeden fall wenn ich das
hier durchziehen dass ich mir etwas zu
essen bestellen muss ja sein also leute
ich habe mir jetzt eine margherita
bestellt pizzabrötchen mit kräuterbutter
und noch eine cola light obwohl
scheißegal ich vielleicht gar nicht
schlafen
naja lieferzeit 50 minuten war angegeben
ich habe als anmerkung geschrieben ich
bin im garten aber ich glaube nicht dass
es funktioniert deswegen ich gebe meinen
eltern bescheid dass noch eine pizza
kommt und dass sie die halt in empfang
nehmen sage ich mal
und ja dann würde ich sagen ich möchte
mich wenn die da ist vielleicht werde
ich noch freunde ein wobei die meisten
heute morgen arbeiten müssen wir haben
heute montag
ja ich glaube das wird ein wir haben
auch schon ein bisschen spät aber ich
versuche mich hängen hier gerade bei mir
in diesem zelt drin weil ich mache sinn
24 schon oder so eine nach experiment
wenn irgendwann auf bock habt könnt
gerne herum kommen wir können diese hot
dogs ihren starten ok mal schauen was
passiert war natürlich nur spaß wobei
das war so der kommentar unter dem
videos ich hab das zwischen 100 mal
gelesen
hot dogs mal hott doch ich habe gerade
eigentlich die pumpe schon so halbwegs
ausgeblendet also man es ist natürlich
schon laut aber man vergisst dass mit
der zeit
leute ich hab grad der nachricht
bekommen dass die pizza da ist während
ich hier irgendwie so ein automagazin
gucke und da würde ich sagen die holen
wir uns mal eben dafür muss ich jetzt
leider wieder raus auch meine ich hasse
es ohne scheiß das ist dass ich lag es
bestimmt schon entspannt 50 60 minuten
rum das ist wirklich das dümmste diese
scheiß luft hier dass die ganze luft
immer an weicht also bis gleich alter
das ging es ich werde immer besser darin
das ist eigentlich kaum was raus
gegangen
okay wir haben jetzt hier ist ja schon
fast kalt die pizza pizzabrötchen
kräuterbutter und cola das ist auch wenn
das ganz ganz ganz aufgeblasen ist
kriegst du das hier gar nicht zu naja ok
schnell wieder in meinem sofa nein mann
ich ahne böses moment mal
obwohl vielleicht habe ich glück
ist natürlich nicht geschnitten
[Musik]
oder die fenster ist echt schon heute
ohne scheiß das heftigste das
allerheiligste ist pizza mit
kräuterbutter
aber ich möchte auf jeden fall gut du
kannst du das nicht einmal ja trotzdem
nicht sonst nicht gemütlich aus oder
warum
na ja die leute haben sich jetzt schon
gesagt glauben eltern gehen jetzt
schlafen die machen vorher macht das
licht aus
nein das war jetzt der strom
nein das war der strom
das ganze ding welt sie zusammengefaltet
ja warum man dass er so dumm gewesen
die fia ist wirklich schwierig lag naja
und sagen das sei auch richtig wir sehen
uns irgendwann gleich wieder
ich muss aufpassen weil irgendwann habe
ich natürlich keine nacht mehr
ich habe nur den leute ich habe jetzt
einfach eine stunde irgendwelche autos
angeguckt aber es hat übers bock gemacht
also mir sondern nicht teilt
ich wollte jetzt eigentlich mal gucken
weil ich muss sagen die playstation ist
ich meine dir gehört mein bruder
ob das spiel drin ist das problem ist
nur dass ich den controller nicht mehr
findet er war doch auf jeden fall schon
mal hier drin also müssen jetzt so half
1 haben er ist auch irgendwie ein
bisschen gruselig weil man kann überall
von überall rausgucken also theoretisch
könnte jetzt gleich hinter mir einer
stehen und ich muss nur auf der kamera
sehen wisst ihr was meinen ich habe
zurzeit muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen
keinen guten schlaf rhythmus ich bin
meistens immer so erst um zwei uhr im
bett und schlafen auf bis 10 uhr also
ich brauche meine acht stunden das muss
ich jetzt aber auf jeden fall wieder
einander nicht in köln bin deswegen habe
ich noch eineinhalb stunden bis sich
dann schlafen geht und eineinhalb
stunden um den controller zu suchen
das machen wir jetzt mal
ich habe ihn perfekt das heißt wir
können jetzt ganz entspannt
die playstation starten dies soll nicht
eingesteckt jetzt muss ich irgendwas
ausmachen
die lampe oder euch noch die
lichterkette aus die braucht ähnlich
funktioniert er nur die hälfte von olaf
weiss noch glauben würde das ist so hell
wenn ich gleich schlafen will
deswegen passt schon mal und jetzt
müsste die playstation auch angehen und
die ist auch schon per hdmi
angeschlossen glaube ich oder auch nicht
mehr so jetzt ist die wenigstens an ok
eine sache die ich aber wirklich sagen
muss es könnte noch größer sein weil man
hat eigentlich also einem bett wird hier
nicht reinpassen auf diesen ganzen
bildern sind ja immer so wetten
die kleinen sind denn diese betten hier
also mein bett passt hier nicht rein
jetzt bin ich immerhin bei playstation
spielt super sonic das spiel heute
wieder so im hintergrund alles
reflektiert das sieht ja ohne scheiß das
sieht ja so heftig aus an will das
circle so was muss ich hier machen also
die qualität stimmt so warum legt das
spiel jetzt nicht also ich habe absolut
keine ahnung was das für ein spiel ist
das sieht aus wie dieses mann
nein nein nein nein
ja
lieber höre ich hab's geschafft ich
hoffe nur 25 dachte ich okay 50 wie soll
bestanden ja gut geil ich muss auf jeden
fall die kamera wieder ausbauen weil
sondern ist der akku gleich irgendwann
leer also die pumpe habe ich wirklich
aus gewendet die hört man gar nicht mehr
ich bin jetzt mal gespannt wenn ich
jetzt sage dass ich jetzt nicht schlafen
gehe ich gleich tun werde also ein
bisschen müde bin ich auf jeden fall
schon
wir sehen uns heute ist jetzt
mittlerweile irgendwie ein bisschen kalt
geworden vor allem im gesicht also es
wird irgendwie mal kälter
ich versuche etwas zu schlafen werden
jetzt kurz nach 22 uhr 18 tun und dann
schauen wir mal ob das hier funktioniert
und ob ich dann morgen wach werde wenn
es hell wird hoffentlich automatisch
natürlich also mittlerweile bin ich hier
schon viereinhalb stunden also die zeit
ging recht schnell und gute nacht und
bis morgen
neuer alex abonniert auf jeden fall noch
den kanal
mich freut es sehr dass diese videos so
gut angekommen sind auch das letzte
jetzt mit dem bericht eingerichtet habe
und dann schaffen was ganz schnell zu
den eine millionen und ihr könnt mir
auch sehr jemand die kommentare
schreiben was ich demnächst mit diesem
ding hier machen soll
solches verlosen oder verkaufen ich weiß
es nicht
naja jetzt aber gute nacht
leute
das problem ist diese scheiß pumpe ist
genau hier und man hört aus so vibrieren
und habe meinem kopf die ganze zeit ich
bin eben fast eingeschlafen und ich
frage mich wieso die lichterkette aus
ist dies eben ausgegeben also ich war es
nicht
naja ok ich versuchs doch mal alles
klappt das wird klappen sonst ich wollte
eigentlich meine airports mitnehmen
damit ich den orten kann
aber diese pumpe die die vibriert so
dass es einfach recht laut wenn man hier
dann so liegt und nichts hört auswahl
dieses dinge man braucht eigentlich
ablenkung
das ist irgendwie so dumm ich könnte
jetzt einfach hochgehen und in meinem
bett schlafen
ich habe jetzt gerade ohne scheiß
geschlafen ich habe eben aufs handy
geguckt und wir haben wirklich schon
nach 4
ich habe auch keine ahnung was das an
strom verbraucht aber diese pumpe die
band hat durchgehend durch mal scheiße
ich glaube der akku hält nicht mehr so
lange deswegen mache ich jetzt gleich
direkt wieder aus - zum glück eigentlich
wieder ziemlich warm
ich kann überhaupt nicht schlafen nur
schlaf halt überhaupt nicht gut und ich
muss man bis nach köln fahren da muss
ich eigentlich ein halbwegs fit seien
alle liegen in ihren betten ich lieg in
einem iglu der von einer pumpe lautstark
betrieben wird
da vorne diese straßenlaternen die
machen halt auch wirklich richtig licht
hier reinkommt mal leute bis dann
so leute ich bin jetzt gerade auf dem
weg zur haustür war ich habe ja einen
schlüssel
also das ist ja auch daran kann man
sehen dass es wirklich so früh ist es
ist nichts los oder brennt sogar licht
herein halt ne scheiße entfuhr erreichen
kann
so leute mittlerweile schon wieder in
köln mir ist aufgefallen also ich habe
das viele schon fertiggestellten das ist
ja kein ende gemacht habt deswegen muss
ich das hier noch machen ich hoffe es
hat euch gefallen ich habe das kurz vor
5 durchhalten aber da musste ich habe
hier mein bester ich hatte am nächsten
tag noch einiges vor sage ich mal so
checkt auf jeden fall war meine neuen
klamotten ab sind ganz oben der videos
verlinkt und aber den kanal daumen nach
oben würde ich mich sehr freuen und wir
sehen uns dann morgen um 19 oder 20 uhr
in die morgen des freitag morgen 20 uhr
freitags am wochenende immer um 20 uhr
am freitag theorie zu hier genug
gelabert vaart rein